si estas son leyes que ya estos estados
tenían ya escritas tenían aprobadas de
forma estatal y precisamente estaban
esperando que la corte suprema de
justicia
tumbar a este caso de roe versus wait
que no no no reconoce el derecho al
aborto como un derecho constitucional
como un derecho federal precisamente
después de esta decisión muchos estados
sobre todo republicanos ya activaron
estas leyes de hecho son 13 estados en
todo el país más de 13 que ya han
activado estas leyes después de la
decisión de la corte suprema de justicia
y entonces hoy es el turno de tres
estados de texas de idaho y de tennessee
son además en estos estados estas leyes
varían no todas se aplican de la misma
forma por ejemplo en tennessee que ya
como ley antes había mencionado ya
tenían estas leyes listas sólo se va a
poder practicar el aborto en caso de que
la madre esté en severo riesgo de salud
en ningún otro caso se va a permitir en
el caso del sexto de violación y si se
va a permitir sin embargo que la mujer
pueda abortar menos en menos de seis
semanas lo que se dice es que en menos
de seis semanas las mujeres no saben si
están o no en embarazo en el caso de
idaho también se aplica el aborto y se
permite el aborto sólo antes de las seis
semanas de gestación y se permite
también en caso de que la madre esté
entre la vida y la muerte ha llamado
mucho la atención y ha generado mucha
polémica el caso de texas en donde no se
permite el aborto a partir de esta
desactivación de la ley contra el aborto
en ningún caso es decir en violación y
en el sexto ni en alto riesgo de la
mujer y no se si no se permite tampoco
antes de estas seis semanas esto ha
generado pues obviamente una ola enorme
de reacciones uno de ellos fue el
político que está de candidato también a
él en la gobernación de texas aspecto
work que salió a criticar la posición
severa del gobernador diciendo que
simplemente estaban desconociendo la
cantidad de trabajo que habían hecho las
mujer y el rol de la mujer en la
sociedad texán a algo parecido fue la
reacción de la vicepresidenta cam anna
jarvis que en su cuenta de twitter dijo
que simplemente estos legisladores no
reconocían el y no tenían confianza en
las mujeres para que sean ellas las que
tomen la decisión de su cuerpo